she was bundle of energy she was the
happiest child
jenny stanley is talking about her
daughter sydney in the summer of 2010
the six-year-old went next door to play
with a friend but no one was there
it's not clear why but on her way back
home she
climbed into her family car and never
got out
with her parents thinking sydney was at
the neighbors she wasn't found until
hours later and the paramedics were
called i loaded her in the ambulance
and came back in and told us we're sorry
there's nothing else we can do for her
it's too late a new study from the group
kids in cars
analyzed hot car deaths since 1990. they
found an average of 39
children die every year but that number
has jumped to over 50
during the past two years most cases
happen when a parent forgets a child is
in the back seat
often believing they had already dropped
off their child at school or daycare
but 26 percent of deaths are like
sydney's
when a child gets in a car on their own
some automakers are installing detection
systems that can prevent a tragedy
on a voluntary basis but safety
advocates want
new laws that would require technology
in all new vehicles
that can detect a child in the car beta
sense
is sensitive enough to detect the
breathing of babies
kits and cars held a virtual press
conference showing off some new options
car companies can install
like this device that alerts parents of
a child is left behind
an unattended child has been detected
and if a child gets into a car
the 3-d imaging radar from viar can warn
parents
it's technology jenny is pushing for if
i can do anything just prevent one
family from having to go through this
she's hoping congress will pass
legislation forcing automakers to
install detection systems
that can help prevent another tragedy
nancy chen
cbs news new york